hello welcome to this video now let's go
d 5 playing uptown girl that the Billy
Joel song no I'm not going to sin the
thing san marino okay yeah should you
five many lines against that f6 is the
most interesting one that is very messy
didn't feel like messy now let's just
play something something solid okay so
it couldn't be six that good I know
queen bee three and ce4 maybe it's got a
very quick Ephraim in this position it's
possible very much possible I can deal
with I can play with it succeeds it's
not a big deal actually hmm and now
before it's very slow I mean slow is
wrong before takes Knight X you can move
the rook and it's not quite clear that
it helped me but i think i can go bishop
a 5 now first yep goes out and leaves
that yeah avoids before this is the
bottom I was searching for quite
desperately what is he doing aiming form
that early but should be to us kind of
interesting see aiming for Bishop f3 and
then if or maybe mm-hmm
it seems to be the case hmm okay
interesting I can you know e5 yeah it's
kind of unusual but I ok then he can
take his seven that's probably not not
that great I wonder if I can do that
actually be four okay okay if he
absolutely insists basically that I do
that so I'm going for it grabbing that
enormous enormous space okay so this is
why I went to e7 I would Knight b6 a4 ok
it tries to somehow can we organize this
position uh-huh pushin h5 not sure what
this was about I'm nice on this happen
anyway ok so when it's junk to a 4 and
now i can i can do both actually but
let's do this yeah some probably yeah i
like my position but it's it's not it's
not something super brilliant
hmm that's a very surprising move okay
I'd already don't get any office moves
it to be honest why is he voluntarily
opening up my bishop I don't quite
understand it especially in kitchen
because Luke a 6 b 6 is very obvious
that i'm attacking be to end every
possible cover is c 2 MV 1 those squares
yeah we'll see what happens so what is
the deal here I can also just globish it
at five now or h5 so I'm pretty good if
you take the droop g8 now then you can
take on geoffroy yeah that's all based
on little tricks what he does so what to
do probably moving the bishop is not a
bad idea to d3 I guess can still take
them home okay
yeah make sure is more or less the time
this is also not bad okay I need to play
a move he's just playing instant moves
and yeah it isn't very good but it is
quick so one minute 15 is already kind
of kind of hmm difficult
check
ya want to be quick now Knight f3 I go
pee should be form one minute ten or
cats it's it's doable it's not
completely completely hopeless check
going for the rook endgame mostly
because of simplicity oh I'm not even
upon up I actually miscounted to be
honest i thought i'm still porn up and
clearly better with an iron money and i
have no problems whatsoever but i'm not
better check
check I broke h1b one if you take so
that you porn check check check
there was threefold yeah I answered you
had to take the drawn out a little bit
of a shame because he was completely
busted of course when I was clearly
clearly far too slow okay so let's have
a look them yeah I blacks position is
very comfortable I've got more space and
always said be to pawn as a source of
attack or sort of attack what kind of
English is that as a target yeah and get
this was just very too tempting now to
go full-scale expansion him very very
nice position Yankee g4s just just a
very bad move it just opens up my my
bishop very as me it did kind of I have
this idea anyway and this just makes it
worse okay here and after after this you
should really lose the game but couldn't
make it work so how do I win actually g3
is strong okay this is very convincing
actually this this and Ruby 6 and this
is falling yeah I think it's not just a
part I've entering on the second rank
which completely ties down this position
does this comes here yeah that's just a
win and here 90 x g4 it's surprisingly
annoying okay that the computers is very
much insisting on that covering
everything so that now this is not
possible i can take caption our because
the rook is protected so yeah what what
is why it's supposed to do the engine
gives this and then just this is this is
also pretty good okay i went here check
no yeah I should go be sure before and
win the game I was at my problem was I
was somehow thinking that I'm a pawn up
in the Rue game game which is completely
ridiculous i'm not but this does win
actually because the night is strapped
the chat or if you this is the is this a
line where the night is not read but
yeah i'm just winning the pawn i
absolutely i miscounted I was really
thinking I'm a pawn up in the rook
endgame and I wanted to play that for
simplicity's sake with the time
disadvantage but okay I'm not appoint
half of it and this end game is is just
equal of course nothing that I can
nothing that I can do he can always
cover his weaknesses i can cover mine
and there is no way forward I've got
more space but that doesn't matter him
so at the end of draw by a three-fold
repetition okay well thanks for watching